SPEAKER: You can
use endpoint checks
to monitor the uptime of any
of your web-facing resources.
To create your first
endpoint check,
click on the "Create
an endpoint check"
button on your
monitoring console.
If the endpoint that you want to
check is an App Engine module,
select App Engine in the
Resource Type dropdown.
Then choose your module.
Then simply test the endpoint.
Here you see that I have
a successful response.
And save the endpoint.
If the endpoint is a GCE
VM instance or a group
of instances, you'll select
Instance from the Resource Type
dropdown.
And then choose
whether you want it
to apply to the group
or a single instance.
Again, select your instance.
Test the endpoint.
And click Save.
Finally, you can use
generic endpoint checks
to monitor the uptime of any
internet-accessible hostname
or URL.
In this case, you'll want
to choose Generic Endpoint
as the resource type.
Then you enter your hostname,
such as cloud.google.com.
You can specify
an endpoint path.
Here, I'll say that I want
to check the monitoring
page on cloud.google.com.
You can specify an
interval for the checks.
Here, I'll choose one minute.
I'll test my endpoint.
And I'll save it.
At that point, you're prompted
to create an alerting policy
so that you can be notified
when the check fails.
And on the next screen, you'll
configure your notification
options.
In this case, I just
want to be emailed
when an endpoint check fails.
So I'll enter my email address.
And then I'll save the policy.
You should note that it
can take a few minutes
for the endpoint checks to
propagate through our system.
To view the status of any
of your endpoint checks,
click on the Alerting
link on the top
of the screen and Endpoints.
From there, you'll see a list of
all of your configured endpoint
checks as well as
their status from each
of our probing locations.
You'll also see an
indication of whether there
are any alerting policies
active associated
with the endpoint checks.
From this page,
you can also edit
any of your endpoint
checks directly.
So that's how you
can get started
using Cloud Monitoring's
Endpoint Check feature.
We hope that it
helps you identify
issues that are impacting
your end users more quickly.